russell n'aura pas traîné avec une
semaine d'avancé sur son calendrier
le comité de concertation sorte de
conseil de défense belge s'est réuni en
urgence ce mercredi l'objectif répondre
au plus vite à la flambée de l'épidémie
dans le plat pays
alexander de croo s'est donc présenté
devant la presse à l'issue de cette
réunion le premier ministre belge a
annoncé un durcissement des mesures anti
qu'ovide pour les quatre prochaines
semaines
face à la hausse des contaminations
c'est clair que c'était une décision
difficile et que pour beaucoup de gens
c'était une déception
et c'est pesant c'est nous deux va
prendre ces décisions là mais si on ne
prendrait pas ses décisions là les
conséquences seraient clairement encore
plus grave que ce qu'on voit maintenant
avec 40% de contamination dans les
entreprises l'assouplissement de ces
derniers mois est bel et bien oublié
rouvert depuis début décembre les
commerces non alimentaires ne
fonctionneront plus que sur rendez vous
eux étaient ouverts depuis mi-février
les métiers de contact non médical comme
l'état thouars où les coiffeurs devront
également baissé le rideau
prévue pour le 1er avril le plan plein
air qui prévoyait la reprise des
activités culturelles et des pratiques
de culte est finalement mise en pause
les rassemblements en extérieur de plus
de quatre personnes sont également
interdits enfin dès lundi toutes les
écoles à l'exception des écoles
maternelles fermeront leurs grilles un
mal nécessaire pour le premier ministre
mais qui ne satisfait pas le ministre
flamand de l'enseignement les dernières
semaines nous avons travaillé ensemble
avec le secteur de l'enseignement pour
pouvoir garder les écoles ouvertes de
manière sûre nous nous sommes accrochés
à la conviction que en tant que société
nous devons donner priorité à
l'enseignement à nos enfants et jeunes
non les enfants à l'école ne sont pas le
moteur du virus
la belgique est particulièrement touché
par le variant britannique devenu
majoritaire parmi les contaminations et
invariants belge vient même d'être
découvert avec 200 décès pour cent mille
habitants
la belgique est le cinquième pays le
plus endeuillé au monde par la crise
sanitaire
côté vaccination 11,4 pour cent de sa
population âgée de plus de 18 ans a reçu
une première dose de vaccin
un chiffre supérieur à son voisin
français